foreign
you know how a lot of professional
Fields require for you to stay in good
standing that you get continuing
education credits
so if you go back and look at this paper
that I've just been reading from the
American Medical Association Journal of
Ethics right below the abstract it says
the American Medical Association
designates this journal-based CME
activity for a maxim of one AMA pra
category 1 Credit available through AMA
Ed hub Physicians should claim only the
credit commensurate with the extent of
their participation in the activity I
looked at that went that's a lot of
acronyms they don't recognize but I
suspect and it turns out I was right
that what that's referring to is the
American Medical association's pra
credit system which demonstrates a
physician has participated in continuing
medical education activities that meet
the requirements of State Medical boards
medical specialty societies specialty
boards Hospital medical staffs The Joint
Commission Insurance Groups and others
and there is a quiz that you can take
based on this article that I've just
been reading to you and if you pass you
get some continuing medical credits from
the AMA
now I took this quiz and I passed it but
I'm going to show you the first of five
and you only have to get four of these
questions right
um the first of five questions in this
quiz uh just to demonstrate what it is
that you need to stay in good standing
with for instance your State Medical
Board your medical specialty Society
your specialty boards your Hospital
medical staffs your insurance companies
Etc okay hand me my screen for a second
so I can find it here Zach this is the
continuing medical
education version of this article they
have in case the article was just too
complex for you they've supplied a an
outline
and then you can actually take the quiz
and you know they have author of author
affiliations over here and again the the
title of the article that you can
demonstrate your complete knowledge of
in order to get um continuing medical
medical education credits through the
AMA is should uterus transplantation for
trans women and trans men be subsidized
the first question of five on the quiz
is which of the following is true about
uterus transplantation in trans women
Anatomy serves as a barrier to doing so
a b hormones make uterus transplantation
and trans women impossible
C obstetric considerations have produced
poor results
d
no uterus transplant has been performed
in a trans woman
obviously
at least one correct answer to this
question is a
Anatomy serves as a barrier to doing so
I however long skilled in taking tests
and gaming such systems know exactly
what they were looking for because it is
also true that D no uterus transplant
has been performed in a trans woman
and that is of course the only correct
answer that they will accept for this
quiz which you would be very well aware
of if you would read the outline
um
considerately provided by the AMA in
order for you to gain as a physician
your continuing medical education
credits and one more time my screen if I
I just want to just want to show off
that I did indeed pass here we go
this you can show this this certifies
that I successfully completely completed
this journal-based continuing medical
education activity should uterus
transplantation for trans women and
trans men be subsidized if I had a State
Medical Board or an insurance company or
anything that I needed to report my
continuing medical education credits to
I could use this to demonstrate that I'm
in full current standing and I have been
keeping up on my medical education and I
really know what's going on now so you
could trust me patience with everything
you need because I have passed this quiz
well you weren't kidding about it's
worse than that that is
unbelievable that I mean it is obviously
a medical version of the social
credit score method for controlling
Behavior
I can't even figure out how you phrase
the obvious indoctrination of doctors so
that they are on board with things that
are clearly a violation of
um the Hippocratic oath and almost
certainly in practice Nuremberg now
to be fair why should we but to be fair
I see I I don't know how many ways that
you can earn you're continuing medical
medical education credits right sure so
like there's there's I do not suspect
that most doctors
are are being funneled through this
particular thing it doesn't make any
difference it doesn't make any
difference what they are doing is they
are causing
a belief system that is radical and
highly suspect to become commonplace by
teaching it as if it were factual and
then testing you on it for a credit that
you need in which you have to answer the
wrong way in order to pass you have to
deny what was the question again you
have to deny that there's uh Anatomy
serves as a barrier to uterus
transplantation for men
to happen to think they're women right
you have to not notice that that is an
obviously correct answer and how many
times do you say lies before you start
to believe them well that's just the
thing and so
here is at least one of the punch lines
of
it's worse than that in this case yeah
how did we get to a place where
virtually the entirety of modern
medicine the medical schools the
hospitals
the doctors the nurses were all saying
false things about the safety and
effectiveness of treatments well this is
the system they look at right and that
system in that system this is not going
to strike people as wildly Beyond The
Pale right this is somehow normal and it
creates why are we so obsessed with this
why do we care I don't care so much this
is also of a piece with when we covered
um
uh McNeil and Fentons
a collection of the jumping of the stats
yeah the Cheap Trick In which
um efficacy was simulated through a
mathematical a statistical artifact
coveted vaccine efficacy was simulated
through a experimental design artifact
right in paper after paper that had been
peer-reviewed and nobody caught it and
our point was actually peer-reviewed
clearly doesn't exist because if it
didn't catch this then it couldn't have
caught anything what's it catcher right
so the point is okay that's the academic
side this is the medical side you have
Pure medical nonsense being taught and
then tested as if it were factually
insightful and a required bit of
knowledge in order to practice
this is madness yes you absolutely do
not want a doctor the only doctor who
passed that test that you want is one
who knew they were lying in order to
pass it who knew they were gaming the
system any doctor who thought that they
were actually participating in
continuing education and responded
correctly is not a doctor that you want
dealing with your medical issues that's
right so that's the world we're living
in and what it means is you want the
only things that make any sense are
going to be off label
you want the things that were reviewed
by peers in a bar
gave you a hard time about stuff in your
study and got you to fix it in a bar you
don't want it peer-reviewed at some
Journal that believes nonsense that's
not going to work it's going to be
counterproductive you don't want doctors
who went through continuing education in
uh silliness like this you want doctors
who care enough about it I mean I think
I think the bar thing is actually
important here you know it doesn't need
to be a bar but you want people who care
deeply enough about the scientific
process and about medicine and about
what it is that they've chosen to
dedicate their lives to that they
continue to talk about it when they're
not literally being paid to do so right
that this is this is in their minds this
is like you know you are you a scientist
after 5 PM well yes right so you know
those of us who think this way it is it
is a way of being it is not something
that stops at the office door in the
paycheck and you know I think peer
review has become just like these
continuing medical uh education credits
just like well I just got tick the Box
tick the Box okay what do I have to do
today I'm gonna pick up milk at the
grocery store I gotta get my CMEs I got
like it's meaningless and it's just one
more thing and a list of meaningless
events that everyone is doing and like
to the degree that some number of
doctors had real passion and and
compassion when they began their work
this will kill it
this this will This Will Destroy it it
will destroy it yeah I I'm reminded I
can't remember the name of the guy but
there was a registered nurse during
early in covid who was reporting that
patients that he
was in charge of he knew very well that
the treatment they were being being
given required that they be gotten up
and out of bed and walked around
um because they were going to drown in
their own fluids if they were left
sitting and they were forbidden to do it
and I remember him saying
I cannot participate in this anymore I
cannot be in charge of these patients
where I know the right thing to do for
them and I'm not allowed to do it and I
have to watch them die
and he quit and I think the point is
okay what role does that leave us where
the people who didn't quit are the last
people you would want in charge of your
care but it's all you're going to have
available to you and there there has to
be some sort of you know you now have
I guess we're the off-label scientists
oh yeah you know we'll review papers
right here on Dark Horse right is that
peer review well I don't know if you're
up to it I guess it is but you know
you don't want something that's been
reviewed by people who didn't spot the
Cheap Trick right right those people are
not qualified whatever their their
degree says yep and doctors who
pass a test like this and didn't know
that they were lying in order to pass it
yeah aren't doctors that you want in
charge of your your health that's insane
nope that's
that's all true that's all true so
um sorry to have blown your mind like
that yeah you know it did it did
actually throw me because you think you
know how ridiculous things get and the
fact is okay uterine transplants if you
think about it of course should such a
thing be medically possible then of
course it would be dragged into this
this trans Madness
um but the idea of the AMA this isn't
some Fringe practice this is the AMA
signing on to it wholesale well then
creating quizzes and continuing medical
education as a way to what fund
themselves
as a way to justify their continued
existence yeah all right so it you uh
you did succeed in uh putting me back on
my heels where I I thought I was pretty
verse pretty well versed in this space I
did not see the the AMA leading the
charge here
[Music]
foreign